some people are going
and you've gone so soft
that you wonder why you're in problems
now
it's because she was daydreaming into
oblivion without direction
i gotta keep turning
i'll keep turning
until he can get
this softness until i can get that
that's where it looks hard
but then you put your sharpness into it
your your perfectionist if you like you
go
you can't do that
i must be getting something wrong
and i showed you this one so he's like
the trick to me and i can't do it on him
that's all right i can't do it on him
even with all my own theory
and that's why i said it was the worst
technique i can think of
because he's now worked out the plan
so there's nowhere to go
so that's why i get there is a complete
contradiction all the time
so don't worry when you get blocked
it's like the nicu
does the person give up because the
wrist is hurting so they blend
the same way as this one doesn't hurt so
he builds up the opposite way and he
gets stronger
[Laughter]
that's the other side of the coin
alright so there's the tammy
him so he's not bothered because uh it's
the other attempt right
a little quick cup of tea 10 minutes
please